يبدو ان الاوضاع في مدينه باخمت لا تسير
كما يريدها الجانب الاوكراني حيث اكدت
سلطات دونتس كالانفصاليه ان قوات فادنار
تقاتل في وسط المدينه ما يشير الى تقدم
لافت كان صعبا على مدار اشهر فهل بدات
معركه الربيع التي توقعها الغرب مبكرا
صعوبه الاوضاع على الارض في بخموت تؤكدها
زياره قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
الجنرال الكسندر سيرسكي مطلع هذا الاسبوع
كيف قالت ان الزياره هي لرفع الروح
المعنويه للجنود ولاجراء محادثات
استراتيجيه مع الوحدات التي تدافع عن
البلده والقرى المحيطه في الشرق يتوقع
محللون عسكريون ان تبذل القوات الاوكرانيه
اقصى جهدها خلال الايام المقبله للدفاع عن
باخموت في الوقت الذي جعلت روسيا من
الاستيلاء على المدينه اولويه في
استراتيجيتها للسيطره على منطقه دوم باس
الصناعيه روسيا احرزت تقدما في الاونه
الاخيره نحو تطبيق حيث لم يبقى سوى حوالي
5000 من اصل 70 الف من سكانها الرئيس
زيلنسكي من جانبه يامل ان يقرر قائده
سيرسكي ضد صد الهجمات الروسيه في باخمت
حيث ينظر اليه وهو احد اكثر القاده
الاوكرانيين خبره ينظر اليه بانه العقل
المدبر لهزيمه القوات الروسيه اثناء
تقدمها في كييف خلال وقت مبكر من الحرب
وفي منطقه خارقييف في سبتمبر الماضيه